a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
stuck in front of bottom now we're here
all right here's the situation
[Music]
the daughters about coming to hunt us
Hello friends I'm nazarez and I'm
sitting next to the cast of Shazam Fury
of the Gods I love that word fury I feel
like I don't use it enough another word
that I just can't get enough of is
shazamly so many of the themes in Shazam
are centered around family and I was
thinking about how there comes a point
in almost everyone's adult life where we
recognize and acknowledged a difference
between our biological family and our
chosen family and I personally have
always loved Shazam for telling a chosen
family story in a positive foster care
story so with all of that in mind I
wanted to ask you guys because I'm so
excited for this movie because we're
adding a new family into the mix and
that is the daughters of Atlas played by
the beautiful Rachel Lucy and Helen
without getting too Kardashian how do
these two families compare as siblings
you know what is a family Dynamic like
with the daughters versus the shazamly
and let's start off with the shazamly
well first of all thank you I appreciate
that that I think it's really cool that
we get to make a movie that does in fact
talk about chosen family and also be so
representative I mean it's it is a
rainbow of ethnicity and culture and
even disability and for us to be able to
bring that to the screen is really
really cool there is so much love
particularly in this in this uh second
installation of the franchise you know
they've now been living together now or
I was at Asher Billy's been a part of
the family for three years now and it's
like really become this cohesive loving
unit but there's also still the drama
that comes along with family but they
would all literally die for each other
they would all do the things that they
were called to do but truly the
daughters of Atlas would do the same
thing I mean you know you guys can speak
to your to your Dynamic but we have a
very different family we have the
classic family you know their three
sisters and in in any sort of classic
family there are always conflicts and
and uh there's love absolutely but there
are conflicts there are jealousies there
there's a classic sort of sibling
rivalry that we have where we didn't
choose to be of the same family we are
born into it you know which is a very
very different Dynamic so we really the
film really plays with that um I don't
want to say too much about that
um I obviously am the older the older
sister but it's very interesting because
I'm I'm the young I have an older sister
and my relationship who I and I
absolutely love my older sister but my
relationship with with her is very
similar to my relationship with these
two which is as the older sister you
assume that your younger sisters will do
what you say and if my my sister tells
me to do anything I do it I never argue
I say yeah well okay fine you know
because it's it's like in My DNA it's my
sister my older sister telling me and we
have a very similar sort of dynamic in
in the movie there's a certain order to
things within a family I think any
family and being sister we have that
kind of like she's so commanding but
then what happens within that you know
what I mean there's there's little
moments and remarks that are made that
you can sort of connect to any family in
that sense and and and contrastly you
guys actually do kind of have a pretty
specific order that you come with in the
movie and we're all in disorder we are
Billy is striving for some order and
Freddie is not helping with that nor are
really the rest of the Shazam everyone's
like doing their own thing nobody wants
to listen I think that's also partly
because
Billy is the leader but he's the leader
because he was chosen by the wizard and
and then he shared his powers with
everybody else but really marries the
oldest kid right so like in theory she
would probably be the leader in that way
and we even like kind of lean on her a
little bit like yo can you help us out
because we don't really know what we're
what we're doing
um yeah so that kind of stuff I love
hearing about these different Dynamics
because as you know I love family and
just I was I've been dying to hear more
about the daughters of Atlas because I
think what is so enticing about this
movie is that these villains aren't
pulled from the comics they're pulled
from Greek mythology and so Helen
because your career is just so
illustrious you've played such Mighty
characters with like immense power and
presence two Queen Elizabeth's Cleopatra
fedra now you're a God but I think this
is one of the first times you're ever
playing a villain so what was that like
for you now being on the other side of
it well of course she doesn't think
she's a villain would you know remotely
and the hespera is doing what she's
doing out of an enormous sense of
righteousness you know the fact that the
power was taken from the gods that that
her mind created chaos in the world
um you know it's an interesting dynamic
as flies are to the boys are we to the
gods is a is a quote from I think
Shakespeare but you know the the sense
that um
that the gods have control of the whole
thing and it's been taken out of that
control uh and and to her mind it's
called it's called caused chaos in the
world that has to be righted so yes she
is the villain in a sense but you know
she comes from a feeling of great great
righteousness
um there is a villain and the villain is
sitting amongst us right here I'm not
going to mention who
though
even the villain any villain is still
the hero of Their Own Story right just
like you're saying so even the villain
sitting amongst us
uh even they still feel very compelled
that they're doing what they're doing
because it's the right thing to do right
we have to have a point of view and a
foundation of what our mission is and I
you know I mean I've been asked several
times what is it like to be the
antagonist or the villain it's like I've
never played a villain I've always been
the protagonist in my story and in my
mind and it's like my you know our we
are here to avenge our father and you
know what Helen was saying is like there
isn't an imbalance and that was not from
our doing so we are there to to succeed
in bringing life back to our world so
it's really a matter of you know where
your perspective is and that is the
beauty of what you have to do otherwise
it's just very flat you can't have
something be that compelling I don't
think if it's so one-dimensional and you
know our our vision of something even if
it's myopic it is it is intentional and
that creates
um a more full story for the audience
especially when we come from uh Greek
mythology you know that there is always
those very in you know dramatic turns
and and what somebody does in turn to
create you know their own tragedy and I
think that you know within the sibling
rivalry Within apology within their you
know trying to find themselves because
these are children as superheroes they
are finding their way as as as
adolescents and that's a struggle
already let alone having this power like
how do you balance that and then like oh
we're gonna take on these goddesses you
know we have to really stand strong to
what we're doing and I think that's
that's what makes it exciting
wow I love how to answer Lucy in that
perspective because there is so much in
this movie and just from Shazam in
general like there is all that
complexity which is why I'm so drawn to
it and while you were talking I was like
reminded of my first ever interview fur
Fandango was actually at Comic-Con with
you Asher Jack was that that one for
Shazam I was so nervous I think we said
shablam like okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I bring that up not to talk about myself
but because I remember when I first
spoke to you about Shazam you were
telling me that there's this 14 year old
that lives inside of you that gets to
come out when you play this character
and so much has happened since that
first movie a pandemic Zach you've been
so outspoken about your mental health
and in the trailer it seems as though
Shazam struggling with imposter syndrome
a little bit so I wanted to ask you what
does tapping into shazam's child like
Wonder do for you mentally well first
let me just correct you I don't have to
wait to play Shazam to tap into my 14
year old self I do that on a regular
basis and uh but as far as being able to
go and like that scene that you've seen
the trailer of me kind of you know
laying there on the couch and talking to
a therapist I do find it very
um I don't know apropos you know given
my entire journey and my mental health
as you as you were talking about to me
it's a very healing it's very
restorative it's very
um look it's very fun I I am living my
actual dreams ever since I was four
years old
all I wanted to do was make people laugh
and smile because I knew it made people
feel good and that made me feel good and
I became very addicted to that which
through therapy I've realized is not a
good addiction all the time uh you you
it shouldn't always be that way you
don't need to find all of your worth
from outside but as an actor being able
to go play a role particularly one that
is so full of life and and and joy and
you know and and bringing something like
this to theaters that are going to
that's going to bring a lot more people
Joy that's very good for my mental
health is like it's so natural to you
that character comes absolutely from
within you I mean we are playing
characters that you know I'm hesper is
outside of me I I didn't create her but
you created Shazam it comes absolutely
from with you so within you so it's just
an incredible melding of of the person
and the character it seems to me
because when Zach talks about Shazam the
love feels like tangible almost I love
talking to you about this character that
you play and when I had first
interviewed you guys I also asked you if
Shazam had a love interest for the first
film and the answer was no so I want to
know for the sequel does Shazam Freddy
or Billy have 11. for the question what
are the questions does Shazam have a
love interest or is it is this his name
or does Freddy and remember
listen listen
he just dies
Billy Shazam
does not have 11 no he does not clear
however
somebody else might right
okay and I don't know that we should go
beyond that
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot to dissect here that we'll
do in Family Therapy later you know
that's so funny when it comes to love
there is this phrase that's been around
forever which is twos a couple Three's a
Crowd and Lucy you have managed to have
great on-screen chemistry with two other
female leads in Charlie's Angels and now
you get to do that here is Calypso with
Rachel and Helen so I wanted to know
what is the secret to building a great
Trio and what did the three of you do to
bond the daughters of Alice to life we
naturally bonded
and we all went shopping as well
we had we celebrated Helen's birthday we
went shopping we had paperback lunches
yeah I mean we just had a very natural
it was effortless it was effortless and
you know what it's not hard to be
friends with people it's just
you know both of these ladies are
generous with their spirit and their
experiences in life and we none of us
were born with the silver spoon in our
mouths and so we come from a very
um
you know from from Earnest hard-working
families and there's there's a struggle
behind it but and from wherever we are
and from wherever we've come from or
where we were born and you know we
understand that we're we're diverse in
that sense but we have a common
denominator which is struggle and so we
were like out there like this is on sale
let's get this we weren't like running
over to life
[Music]
we were just like ourselves eating out
of you know paper bags and just enjoying
ourselves and and not drawing attention
to ourselves you know we were just very
undercover and that's how we you know I
think that we enjoy our lives we don't
try to go to the most fancy popular
restaurant where we know everyone's
going to be or there's going to be
Paparazzi yeah that's not what attracts
us to each other or to other people
frankly and I just I love that about
ourselves you know we we are I think
we're all very private people
um
it was really effortless I think Rachel
can speak to that as well I mean it we
felt like peers you know obviously we're
fans of each other's but but it wasn't
the first thing that came to mind it was
it came from such a raw and I think our
approach to the work as well I mean it
all three of us were stepping into an
unknown Arena you know we were jumping
into a pool we'd never swim in before
these guys were familiar with with those
Waters but us three had never been there
before so um I think the way we
approached it was we all we all just all
looked at each other stood at the end of
the pool looked at each other and held
our noses and jumped in you know
it was my second movie ever so I was
just taking notes all the time anything
that anyone would say to me would be
like write their town it's going to be
important it's going to be on the test
and so it was just you know to come into
a film where I got to spend so much time
with women was so amazing and it's a
rarity sometimes on sets that you get to
actually have whole days of where you're
just working on a scene with women and
to get to call these wonderful women my
sisters on an offset is a gift in and of
itself so yeah I love that you mentioned
second movie Rachel because I have to
tell you as someone who's been on the
sidelines your trajectory has been so
remarkable to watch
congratulations thank you very much
this is really weird because it like you
don't even when you we were making the
movie it you forget she care you carry
yourself very very maturely
intellectually you have a you have a
deep repertoire of understanding of a
lot of different things and different
art and all that jazz you really do so
you forget that you are 21 one
but also that you haven't been working
for a long time which I think probably
lent itself very well to stepping into a
relationship with these two ladies who
haven't been working for you know quite
some time and to to all find that Common
Ground so you know
right and occasionally that little girl
would open her mouth and this
unbelievably beautiful sound would come
out which is her singing voice and you
know it's easy to forget that when we
just sort of sitting around oh yeah
she's got this incredible instrument in
that beautiful body
um and just from occasionally she
allowed us to hear that she was just
humming
it was very casual like a little Snow
White
on the shoulders and carry her away I
love this love because a lot of people
don't know that you were cast in this
film before many people had even seen
West Side Story which is it wasn't out
but I want to ask you about your
character Rachel because at first
um I thought it was Athena right who has
a connection to Wonder Woman I was wrong
right and theater and director David F
Sandberg has said that there are a lot
of twists and turns when it comes to
your character very mysterious what can
you tell us about Ambia um I can tell
you that I didn't know what I was
auditioning for when I auditioned that's
how secretive it was and so it wasn't
yeah
so that's that's the thing so when David
called me to offer me the role uh after
I had been auditioning then he was like
do you know what happens when I was like
No And so he explained her whole uh
trajectory and I thought that's juicy
I'm excited and so I get to kind of
flip-flop between this real world and
the God Realm and getting to be like a
teenager at in high school with these
two buffoons and then also like go face
to face with that buffoon over there and
all the while getting to also be a
goddess and so uh all of the intricacies
of her relationships and friendships and
sisterhoods in the film are really
amazing and I'm excited for people to
see and to learn more about her I mix
first of all buffoon is also a word I
need to add to my repertoire I use it a
lot here but I'm also so excited to just
really see more about all of your
characters Especially Yours and really
just the future of the DC EU in general
you know Zach there's so much for DC
down the line coming on the way I don't
want to ask you to speculate but now
having done two Shazam films and written
a Shazam comic book story what would
your pitch be to James Gunn for future
Shazam movies
[Music]
I mean I mean honestly like I I really
I've tried to wrap my head because I
love I mean I love storytelling and
producing and writing and all these
things and I and I and my mind is always
loves to kind of run ahead and be like
oh what wouldn't it be cool if this or
not the other but with our particular
franchise it's it's been very difficult
for me to wrap my head around like what
would be the next kind of move partly
because all the kids are growing like
weeds so I don't even know how that
applies to the dynamic of what the
movie's going to be
um oh look I think if we sex yes
amazing I actually really think I think
it would be really fun
um I think it'd be really fun I've never
seen a superhero
zombie movie like I I really genuinely I
would love to kill zombies I think it
would be really fun to do let's just
saying
well there's something like that not an
undead Shazam but rather we're having to
fight off like hordes of like the undead
I think actually I was thinking more Eat
Pray Love so oh yeah
just eating drinking vino and being like
who am I and I know I love myself
no that was amazing that was beautiful
also I can't believe I just I'm in Helen
mirren's presence hearing her speak
Shakespeare and then just say sex like
that for me
um guys I'm so excited for this before
we end this interview I would love to do
a couple rapid fire questions I'd love
for you guys to answer as families cool
um first answer that pops in your head
the first one's for the shazamly
what movie would the shazamly pick for
family movie night
there it is I said big but I think I
agree with tangled I'd like to watch
Tangled actually yeah
guys it's a banger if you haven't seen
it it's a Disney animated movies
Eugene fits Herbert for the initiation
what movie would the daughters pick for
family movie Gladiator
Clash of the Titans or something like
that I think Gladiators
like they're on their their our costumes
yeah are very glad so not Hocus Pocus
yeah okay what music would you find on
the daughters of Atlas playlist
Spice Girls
yeah I was getting more classic rock but
I think for the action scenes we can
definitely do for the action PC where
Helen is kicking Zach's ass
kickery
Intel what what
means well
stupid like like The Brady Bunch theme
song
we're gonna have some great dance pop
we're gonna have some dually Buffs
certainly on that playlist guys I don't
know what we're even talking about we
have fun we have fun okay this last one
will be family versus family which
family would host the best dinner
I for one cannot wait to see this movie
meal that all these people have cooked
up for us my friends tickets to Shazam
Fury of the gods are available right now
on fandango.com thank you guys so much
for your time thank you for your time
and I think we should end this interview
with One really obvious word that's
really fun to say right
um